are we really about to head back to the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter
according to an anonymous report by we
got this covered it could be a
possibility the outlet citing anonymous
sources claims that the studio is
developing a brand new Harry Potter
movie featuring the three original stars
Daniel Radcliffe Emma Watson and Rupert
grints the purported project is an
adaptation of the stage play Harry
Potter in the cursed child written by
Jack Thorne from a story he wrote with a
JK Rowling and two-time Tony
award-winning theatre director John
Tiffany given the stage play success
it's not out of the realm of reality
that Warner Brothers would want to make
big bucks with a future film adaptation
however we can puncture quite a few
holes in this rumor for starters this
isn't the first time we've heard reports
that Warner Brothers wants to turn Harry
Potter and the cursed child into a film
in August 2016 just two months after the
play began its London previews New York
Daily News ran an article claiming that
Warner Brothers was interested in
adapting the play for the silver screen
in a project that would debut as soon as
2020 the studio was said to have hoped
that Radcliffe would board the film to
reprise his most famous role this report
started a hot fire of speculation that
began burning up social media in
September 2016 Warner Brothers
representatives issued a statement he
bumping the rumour Harry Potter and the
cursed child is a stage play with no
plans for there to be a film
additionally there's the issue of
whether Radcliffe Watson and Grint would
genuinely want to come back to the
franchise in a 2018 interview with The
Guardian Grint said it was nice to
breathe the fresh air and now I'm really
enjoying stepping further away from that
blue-screen world that doesn't exactly
inspire a lot of confidence in the idea
that grant would be willing to come back
to the Harry Potter universe for another
movie for his part Radcliffe has said
that he's not really interested in
appearing again as Harry Potter oh good
I don't need this the Vettes for the
character it also seems like he's done
with the character in more ways than one
in November 2018 Radcliffe admitted that
he had no intention of ever watching
Harry Potter and the cursed child since
he would feel like he was being
monitored for his reaction I feel like I
would not be a relaxing evening in the
theatre watching but I feel like I would
be being watched for my reaction
those comments pose an important
question if Radcliffe doesn't even want
to see the play why would he want to be
in a film adaptation of it
unsurprisingly Watson has taken a
similar stance as her potter co-stars on
the matter asked during a Sirius XM
interview if she would ever return to
the Wizarding World
Watson answered asked me in another 10
years since Warner Brothers suffered
disappointment with the less than
fantastic performance of fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald it's
possible that the studio is looking to
get its Potter verse back on track by
finally going through with Harry Potter
and the cursed child it's also possible
that the studio was willing to spend
whatever money it took to convince
Radcliffe grant and Watson to join the
film knowing that their involvement
would boost audience interest though the
three stars have done well for
themselves outside the potter franchise
none have reached the same level of
success they attained during their time
as witches and wizards with what might
have been major money on the table and
the promise of even more success it's
possible that Radcliffe Grint and Watson
really might accept an offer to star in
Harry Potter in the curse child still
there's nothing that's actually been
confirmed and curse child
representatives in New York reportedly
declared on September 5th there are no
plans whatsoever for a movie if anything
comes out to make this rumor more
credible rest assured that will fill you
in with all the details check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]